When was the most troubled person? Well,
that's my defense of Roseanne. You know,
all these people were coming after
Rosanna. I'm like, you don't understand.
She's bad. She's, she's not just
batshit. She got in a car accident. He,
she had severe brain damage.
She's on all sorts of medications.
He has multiple personality disorder.
She's drinking,
she's on Ambien and she's seven years
old. What the fuck do you want? Right.
What you want from this lady. And you
spoke that way. And so did norm, you know,
norms talked about Louie and Roseanne
and the same way you that like, Yo man,
she's bat shit crazy. First of all,
if you're going to her for, for,
you know, if you're going to
her for political discourse,
you know my one or you evaluate your
light comes on you, that's your fault.
Yeah. You, yeah.
And that doesn't mean either one of
us agree with exactly what you wrote.
It's just how she got there. But that's
what also was, she's so funny, you know,
if you go back and watch
Roseanne in the early days,
well that show was fucking heavy. It was
a great show. And her standup before,
even before. That was fantastic. Yeah.
I put her in the top 20 of all time.
She was brilliant. She was brilliant.
But it's also a monster man.
Like there was nobody like her before.
Like she was just as brash.
I don't give a fuck. She was
like a man kill, like, like, uh,
like, like a world class stand up. I mean,
I remember like when that show came
on, just seeing that house, I was,
I had never seen a house like that
on television. You know what I mean?
Closer to what we knew
then what I had ever seen.
My house didn't look like the Cosbys,
you know what I mean? I was like,
maybe Archie bunker, you know,
it was like a little bit closer,
but it's when people are batshit
crazy and someone reacts to that with
confusion, not confusion
with contempt. I'm like,
you understand their bat shit crazy
and it's part of why they got to where
they're at. Don't, don't
ask surprise now that,
that someone said something loony.
Yeah. This many years after.
You know what I mean? It. It it,
it just seems strange to me
that now you're blown away.
She's been saying batshit
crazy shit for a long time.
I think it's also part of this new
culture that we have in where people just,
they find a target and they attack.
Of course. It's like if, if you have,
if there's any sort of weakness,
like if you have chickens
and one chicken gets sick,
that's what that pecking order thing is.
Sean chicken doesn't feel good.
The other chickens,
they don't,
they don't like make moral
judgments on this chicken.
They just find a target the
site along with that chicken,
so they start fucking it up. Right. And
this, it happens with dogs. It's a horse.
It's an animal thing. It is
human beings. We have to,
if we're going to be real, if we're
gonna, if we're going to be compassionate,
we're really going to be compassionate.
If we're really gonna like try to
engineer a better culture and a better
community, we got to stop that. I agree.
We've got to just stop attacking people.
Like, she didn't, I believe I talked
to her on the phone, just me and her.
She did not know that lady
was black initially. She
looked at that lady, she goes,
she looked Jewish. She looks like me.
She, that's what she said. I believe you.
I believe her too.
I think she was just cracking a joke
fucked up on ambien short and drinking and
smoking weed all night. And, but
no one cares what her intent was.
All they care is, I got a
green light. That's a target
we're going to go in. Well,
here's my issue with the, the
modern, the modern left is,
is they talk compassion. But
there though they pounce. It's,
I feel like a man with no country
now too. Cause I don't, I don't,
the modern left isn't something that
I gravitate towards and neither is the
right. And when I was growing up and
listening to public enemy, you know,
and that left of it,
it changed.
It changed and I didn't. Yeah, yeah, yeah.
And you, and you have these people, um,
I don't know where I stand anymore,
man.
I think there's this rational left
leaning people that are against
discrimination and for
welfare and for food. I look,
I was on welfare when I was a kid.
If people say I shouldn't be on welfare,
well what the fuck? Right. My parents were
on, well, no, I came from a poor family.
We had food stamps and eventually
they did better and we got off of it.
But if you want to tell me that, that
doesn't help, that fed me. Absolutely.
So how could I ever go against that?
And that was a part of my childhood.
Solutely there's all these things that
people want to associate with being,
you know,
like with the left or right.
I think there's just a gigantic
problem with people being tribal.
That's what it is. It's tribalism at
its, at its highest degree, which,
and since I've been alive, I haven't
seen, never seen it like this for Fords.
I think we know why, but, well it's
facilitated not just by Trump and,
but it's also by the ability to
communicate instantaneously, of course,
without any consideration.
And you could just tweet something or
make a youtube video about something
instantaneously. Sure. Roseanne's
ability to tweet that. Yeah.
That quickly with the phone is why Song
Kirsch show costs millions of dollars.
People lost their jobs. ABC Junk, you
know, it's either going to do the Connors,
guess what? That show's gonna
fucking sink like the titanic.
Of course it's going Roseanne.
Get the fuck out of here, man.
Roseanne without Roseanne,
right? Three episodes.
That's like flavor free diet.
Coke tastes like water and
just have water motherfucker.
It's diet coke though, without
the flavor. It's true. It's true.
And I don't, um, it's just,
it's the hypersensitivity and it's like
the ability for anyone right or wrong to
be able to something right
then. Right where you would
have, you know, if, if, uh,
you're doing fear factor in
rolling stone interviews, you,
there's a thought process there and,
and there's editing and you're sitting
there and you're talking with a
journalist. All of that's
gone, man. It's like it,
that's what it's come down to.
You know, we have all, all three.
It was our phones in our pockets.
You can say something crazy right now.
If we stubbed our toe right,
it's nice, steady job, fuck this,
Blah Blah and all of a sudden you're done,
your son good in that because the tyranny
of these gigantic organizations like
if they were tyrannical,
if they did have an agenda,
if they were trying to smear you,
you were fucked.
He had no recourse and they did that.
Too many people,
I'm sure there's unscrupulous journalists,
but also journalistic
integrity takes a backseat to,
because now they have to get clicks.
Like these people are real journalists
are fighting for their lives. Absolutely.
Cause these publications going under,
well real journalism is almost dead.
It's not totally dead but it's,
it's hurt.
But like I was got emphysema
like the Alex Jones thing. Right.
Whether I agree with shit he says
are not corporations shut him down.
And that to me that scary that the
corporations can decide what we are.
Well to hear really well.
I was having a good conversation about
this last night with some friends and
they were talking about whether or
not things like youtube or Twitter or
Instagram should be regulated
like utilities where anybody
can use it. You know,
like you have the right to get the power.
Like if you have, if you have a house,
you're, you have the right to, you pay
your money, you get your power turned on.
It's a utility.
Maybe a channel like that,
whether it's a youtube
or whether it's Twitter,
maybe a channel should be treated like a
utility, but then the question is like,
what is it exactly that is good
enough to get you kicked off?
Because I've seen some horrible shit.
People have read or written rather on
Twitter that, and they're still on, right.
I've seen shit, whatever. He's
being a whatever, you know,
this is why he was brought down.
I've seen people say much worse shit
thing was the sandy hook and it was that
the sandy hook thing was he said
that he thought that it was fake.
He's since disavowed that,
but they don't care if you disavow things.
It's like they have this thing on you now.
You said that the kids didn't die.
They definitely did.
Let's get rid of you.
But are you saying that people
aren't allowed to make mistakes?
Are you saying that people aren't
allowed to evolve their thinking?
Are you saying that people aren't allowed
to say things that are wrong because a
lot of people say things in a wrong,
but is it only things that are
wrong about children? Like where,
what does the line,
I don't know where lines are anymore
and I don't know who's the one drawing.
Well,
it's these people that either are the
CEOs or the stockholders or the CFO's,
whoever it is that, that is in the
meeting dictating these standards.
They're deciding,
and these are gigantic corporations
that we were just talking about this.
I don't think they ever anticipated this.
I think when they made Twitter they
thought it'd be, like Jamie was saying,
it was a fun way to like tell your
friends, you know, uh, you know,
Vinny pads and Joe Rogan to go into the
movies and that's what you would do.
That's what Twitter was. It
was just like, I'm at, I'm,
I'm eating pizza at the mall.
Yeah. It wasn't anything crazy.
And then people started using
as a platform for, I don't
know what, uh, you know,
Vinny pads and Joe Rogan to go into the
movies and that's what you would do if
that's what Twitter was. It
was just like, I'm at, I'm,
I'm eating pizza at the mall.
Yeah. It wasn't anything crazy.
And then people started using as
a platform for, I don't know why.